Поховання Олександра Захарченка у Донецьку
організували наче прощання з видатним державним діячем.
Сепаратист Захарченко не лише 4 роки очолював одну із самопроголошених республік,
він також підписував "мінські угоди".
Втім, в Європі його загибель великою подією на стала,
і наслідків для мінського процесу аналітики не чекають.
Що стосується мінських угод, то нічого не змінюється.
Навіть якщо під угодами стоїть його підпис, він не належав до тих, хто сприяв їхній реалізації.
Скоріше навпаки - він негативно впливав на втілення цих домовленостей.
Захарченко загину внаслідок вибуху 31 серпня в кафе "Сепар" у центрі Донецька.
Основні версії - це російський слід, український слід,
і третя - розбірки всередині самої так званої "ДНР".
Спостерігачі звертають увагу на те, що не стало цілої низки ключових фігур
на окупованих територіях України, з якими асоціювалися так звані ДНР і ЛНР.
Захарченко був чи не останнім з решти лідерів сепаратистів першої хвилі.
Наприкінці листопада 2017 року голова так званої Луганської республіки Ігор Плотницкий
подав у відставку через стан здоров'я.
Європейські аналітики вже губляться - а хто тепер, власне, є лідерами цих територіальних утворень?
В Парижі і Берліні заявили, що смерть Захарченка не повинна зашкодити мінському процесу.
Канцлерка, федеральний уряд, міністр закордонних справ
в будь-якому випадку продовжуватимуть сприяти мирному процесу на Сході України.
І насильницька смерть Захарченка робить зусилля із реалізації мінських угод ще більш необхідними.
Цікаво, що влітку торік Захарченко оголосив про створення держави "Новоросія"
на базі самопроголошених ДНР і ЛНР, як спадкоємиці України,
з подальшим приєднанням до Росії.
І це не єдиний випадок, коли Захарченко, на думку західних експертів,
був радше перешкодою мирному процесу і підривав його своїми радикальними вимогами.
За Росією, як правило, останнє слово в цих так званих" республіках ".
Вона дає ресурси, без яких вони не можуть жити.
Тому, на мій погляд, важливо не те, хто очолює ці" республіки ",
а те, який має намір щодо цього процесу Росія.
Водночас у Москві вважають, що вбивство Захарченка
ускладнить налагодження мирного процесу на Сході України.
Українська ж сторона обмежилася коментарем СБУ, в якому висловили припущення,
що смерть Захарченка - наслідок кримінальних розбірок в так званій ДНР,
або лідера самопроголошеної республіки ліквідували російські спецслужби.
У тому, що істину в цій справі коли-небудь встановлять, більшість спостерігачів сумніваються.